Marie Marie Marie is going to be our
first speaker and he's really gonna look
at dispelling some of the bits we may
have about Africa today so Martin Marie
it's a ten years old professor that come
in college urban clinical team I just
learned a fascinating story he began his
academic career as a sociologist with
the strong foundation urban geography
his current research engages the field
of urban studies and planning global
urbanism cultural geography distressed
urbanism development historical
sociology and African Studies in
addition to six books increased Roden
and volume has produced posts and 17
journal articles and book chapters that
focus on the verge geographical areas in
the world at different historical period
he's contained two books on city
building and states and politics in
Johannesburg after apartheid his current
research focuses on two fields of
anchoring first the trajectories of
global urbanism at the start of the 21st
century and segments burned for a master
plan to basically design private cities
built from scratch especially those
Perlina construction or at the planning
stages and answers and I think we were
talking on the Ignite contrast to the
organic sania volunteers that we looked
at yesterday to look at these cities
from scratch I'm gonna stop there only
to add that I think if you can only say
because professor Murray taught for many
years of things in my alma mater and I'm
stabbing they were took the course with
you so I get this
well thank you very much I'm really
happy to be here and I it's gonna it's a
difficult task that I have because you
really haven't over the course of your
your your study in this program hadn't
had a lot of time to really look at
contemporary cities and city building in
Africa so I have to sort of fill in a
lot of gaps and it's a it's a quite a
daunting task that I have in it Garth
has so I'll do the best I can partly
what I'm gonna try to do is dispel what
I think are sort of like lingering myths
which you may hold or may not hold but
that's sort of the way I'm going to
tackle this and more kind of in in a
framework of sort of anecdotes and maybe
some stories to try to you know like to
sort of sort of open up some space to
get you to think about things and maybe
ways that you haven't before I'm going
to pass around two brochures that I that
I have and and I definitely need these
back the first one is a place called and
I'll talk a little bit about this one in
in a discussion later
it's called stain City it's between
Johannesburg and Pretoria it's a
complete city built by a single private
developer named Dow Steen Dow stain who
basically has brought all these
businesses into this particular place
and built a walled city between Janice
Berg and and Pretoria so it a lot of
this is highly stylized it probably
never quite reached expectations that
you find in the in the picture book the
second one I'm going to pass around is
called muchachos
I'm a taco City it's about sixty
kilometres south of Nairobi
and it's one of the kind of planned
cities that I'm going to talk about and
and and show some videos about this is
one of maybe three or four there's
Kansas City outside of Nairobi about
another ten kilometers south from LA
Chacos there's tattoo city north of
Nairobi there's a place Garden City
which is closer to the city center
another place called two rivers or three
rivers all of these fit this modeled and
I'm going to talk about AB new city
building in in Africa this place
basically is not built it may or may not
ever be built but I wanted to share with
you the kind of stylized images in here
that that sort of have sort of captured
the imagination of those that are trying
to think about these things and and
possibly build them there's a lot of
talk that places like machakos or really
speculative investments that are not
really ever intended to be built but
simply to get people to buy the land for
the people who now own land and highly
abided highly inflated prices but that's
something we'll find out in the future
so if you just pass them around take a
look at them so let me just start with a
few kind of general a few general
comments one and Africa is not a country
there's a good friend of Garson mine a
guy named from South Africa named John
Jacobs who has a blog calls it called
Africa is a country which is a spoof but
it's a great thing if you ever want to
look at what's going on today in Africa
it's it's it's very very political and
very sort of up to date and themes and
so forth so Africa is a country but my
thing is Africa is not a country and
what in part what I want to say there is
that there's incredible diversity
there's incredible diversity in cities
there's incredible diversity in regions
there's incredible diversity in
histories and so there's a tendency I
think sometimes to sort of conflate or
condensed Africa it as one place and I
want to sort of disabuse you of that my
own views are strongly shaped by
Johannesburg it's a place that I first
went to in 1977 before I was born
oh that's a joke to say that then when I
was more of a youngster and it's a place
that's changed unbelievably but to sort
of give you a sense of the historicity
of places in Africa a city like Luanda
in Angola can probably trace back that's
hid the history of city building there
probably 300 years or so it was a
Portuguese Angola was a Portuguese
colony they built up Luanda over a long
period of time
Luanda and Maputo another Portuguese
another city that was part of the
Portuguese Empire both are strikingly
similar to Lisbon they're both built on
base they both reflect the kind of
architecture and stylistics of of
Portugal and they both have long
histories connected to the slave trade
and connected to the kind of extraction
of resources from the center of the city
from the center of the country's East
and West Africa in contrast I could use
some water thank you in contrast
Johannesburg is a city that was not
really officially inaugurated until 1886
after the discovery of gold and within
the subsequent the next two decades or
so the area around Johannesburg was
producing 40 percent of the world's gold
and the city grew up around that and
still reflects the fact that it's just a
dirty old mining town I do like the
place but it is a dirty old mining town
this another point that I want to say is
that urbanization in Africa is
proceeding at an incredibly rapid pace
we tend I think a lot of times the sort
of imagery of Africa is very rural and I
do think that um oh thanks very much I
do think that that much of the the kind
of urban dynamics are ignored
not only in scholarship but also ignored
and the kind of imagery where Africa is
going on in the future so I'm kind of
I'm gonna try to anticipate a little bit
another a couple of phrases and then
I'll show you a bit of a video here or
concepts that I want to have us unsettle
a bit one is the term we use it a lot
and it term African cities I I'm a
little reluctant if I ever say it I
really don't mean it because I don't
think there's anything it's not African
cities as if African cities are
different from Asian cities are
different than Latin American cities and
so forth I want to see it as cities in
Africa the other and that's related to
this idea the sort of hybridity of the
places that that really are assemblages
of features that are drawn from all over
the world if when I look at your
Hannah's burg every single urban issue
in the urban scholarship you can find it
in Johannesburg from the mundane to the
extreme from issues with immigrants to
issues with large-scale capitalist
investment to issues of informality and
so forth and so on you can find it
there's 200 and something informal
settlements around Johannesburg alone
so-called slums are just around you
Hannah's burg that's not just in the
country as a whole
it's a johannesburg the metropolitan
region has 40% unemployment yet at the
same time it has some of the richest
suburbs and the fanciest malls I've ever
seen anywhere in the world so there
these places are really extreme and it's
hard to make any kind of generalizations
from one anecdote or from one experience
so I want to get away from this idea of
African cities and look at more cities
in Africa and places that are reflecting
global influences local inflections and
hybrid relationships that are drawn from
other parts of Africa other parts of
Asia and so forth so if there's nothing
that that essential eise's them as
african is is my view a second term I
think
or a theme that we need to be careful
with and it's hard to talk about is the
term tribe my experience in Africa is
very much southern African if you went
to ordinary people in Johannesburg and
use the word tribe they would be
repelled it's not a word that resonates
it's a word that seen as basically a
reflection and part of apartheid of the
past it's not an identity for people at
all they may identify by by language
group they may identify by historical
roots in a certain area of the country
but they don't identify per se by tribe
that may change in other parts of Africa
which I know less but I just wanted to
raise that as a point that you know just
be careful with that that term to others
that I'll say something about quickly
before I show you something the kind of
the common tropes that usually resonate
when we taught when we talk about cities
in Africa particularly these big
sprawling mega cities of hyper growth
like Kinshasa or Legos are their terms
slum and informality slum of course is a
bit of a controversial term I mean some
people it fits within that same genre of
terms like favela or ghetto
I myself and there's a literature that
basically attacks using the word slum I
myself have am not that critical if we
use the term carefully if we really
understand what's actually happening I
spent a certain amount of time in Kibera
outside of Nairobi or in Nairobi
actually which some people argue is the
biggest and garthe can probably say more
about this the biggest slum in Africa
it's an incredibly vibrant place I mean
and there's a highly
evenness in that place itself from
dozens and dozens of small manufacturing
sites where people are making things for
sale whether it's furniture or whether
it's tools or whatever they're making
there and selling it elsewhere on the
one side so there's a it is a kind of an
enrichment in that place at the other
side there's extreme poverty and
deprivation in extreme hierarchies in
terms of age gender and ethnic origin in
that place itself so a term like slum
carries a sort of a centralized idea as
if it's all the same and when in fact
they're not they're highly
differentiated places that have their
own internal contradictions and so forth
the other term informality
in the literature there tends to be a
kind of strong separation between the
term formal and the term informal and
formal sort of fits into that category
of officially sanctioned legal open
visible regulated informal tends to be
treated as invisible illegal unregulated
and so forth and and and so one sort of
represents in the in the conventional
literature or formal represents kind of
orderliness goodness and efficiency and
informal represents the opposite chaos
illegality and so forth I want to
disabuse us of that idea and to say that
actually formal and informal are really
tied very very closely together
they can't really be separated and maybe
as we proceed I'll make some comments
about Detroit which is like my
neighborhood does Ann Arbor is basically
a suburb of Detroit
and I've learned a lot from thinking
about thinking about Detroit to give one
example of the blending of formal and
informal is the first time I went to
Luanda and Angola to get from the
airport into the center of the city in
Luanda the city has about half the
population of the country it's maybe who
knows anywhere four to eight million
people
unknown actually it's a big bulky city
with the remnants of Portuguese British
architecture built on a hill and so
forth but as you drive into the center
of the city it's you know like driving
from LaGuardia to New Haven you know
it's it's a traffic jam except the
traffic there goes a little bit slower
and there's men that line the streets
selling everything from water to pens to
backpacks to irons on and so forth and
that's what classically we think of as
being the informal economy but if we
unpack it and look at it underneath what
we see is something that's actually
quite different that's happening what's
happening is that shopkeepers in the old
downtown realizing that their street
traffic of people walking past their
shops is really limited because of
overcrowded streetscape with cars that
in order to expand their business they
work on a kind of consignment a
consignment business and they give ten
mops to a guy in the morning who then
takes the business away from the shop
and moves it around the city so there in
Turkey in Turkey connected and the work
that I'm starting to do on cities
elsewhere is to realize now that city
building process is really taking place
through exceptions that the formal rules
of land
zoning are being violated and exceptions
are being made and this is nothing other
than informality and so in other words
formality and informality are terms that
really are blended and can't be seen as
separate the term slum is not in a
centralized category but actually a
highly differentiated category where
informal settlements or slums or
whatever have their own historicity
have their own dynamics and they can't
it's hard to generalize about them
except to say that generally speaking
it's mainly poor very poor people who
who live there so I'm gonna just show
about three or four Tara said that she
made this this particular video
available for you for me it's it's one
of the greatest we'll talk about an EM
you know I'm gonna only show three or
four minutes of it
it's about cities in Africa
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay this particular video presentation
is about 11 minutes long I would
encourage you if you want to see it I
mean I would guess that it's a bit of a
surprise for you what it it's highly
stylized it's it's propaganda I think in
in the classic good sense in a sense
that it's it's one-sided it shows
one-sided picture notice that there's no
people and that these cities are
basically seen through the lens of kind
of architectural monument ality and we
could proceed for the next seven or
eight minutes or so and show more and
more of the same of the same imagery
it's one sided in the sense what you
don't see are informal settlements poor
people and so forth which make up the
majority of many cities not all but many
cities in in Africa but what it does I
think is that just it I think for me it
graphically portrays this idea that the
kind of large-scale city building
projects have been in operation in
Africa for quite some time and have
really reshaped a built environment that
look very very similar to cities that we
would see in the so-called West and
these images in some ways put to shame
images that one would have of Detroit or
you know or Flint or or so forth so in
other words what I'm trying to get us to
think about is that there's some
elements of city building in Africa that
are certainly on a par if not exceeding
what we would find in the West and that
that it's not and I wanted to spell this
idea that somehow we have to look at
Africa is somehow backward and needing
of remedial work and somehow having to
catch up with us I mean I think Detroit
has to catch up with Africa
the joke that I make and somewhat
facetiously and I'll say it didn't so
don't write you know don't think that I
think this directly in these terms but
if Detroit allowed ten thousand
Nigerians to come it would be a
completely different place in two years
it would be a much more vibrant healthy
place than it is today
and because Nigerians would know what to
do and we could extrapolate to other
countries in Africa as well
I just want to say something and it make
some general comments about cities
there's a lot of discussion in the
literature and I think the discussion
really points in in a proper direction
they're around the death of the city now
we don't see it as much living in this
part of the world but this image that we
have and it certainly persists in the
literature and I think it's embedded
itself in our minds these images that we
have of cities and what cities are and
how they're shaped and what what form
they take they take still persists maybe
in the United North America and Western
Europe but is really not the way cities
are being built in the rest of the world
and these these these kind of ideas of
the city as a coherent unified place the
city that has a central business
district a center or even multiple
centers and then dissipates at the edges
into kind of low-density residential
suburbs before it disappears into the
frontier in the hinterland that idea
strongly shapes the way that we think
about cities and the way we experience
cities but if we look at city building
on a global scale it's no longer like
this cities are being built in a much
more haphazard way the kind of
in-between city or the the mass
large-scale metropolitan regions were
what used to be called cities really
blend one into another where the
environment is highly layered and highly
checkered in terms of what can be what's
where the density occurs and where the
low density occurs it what we really
don't have the classic city certainly in
Africa and China we don't have that
classical city anymore what we have is
mass urbanization that spreads in all
directions in a way that's hard to fit
within these categories of center
periphery central business district
residential suburb and so forth and in a
way what I want to argue as well is
another term that we've sort of carried
along with us is the idea of the third
world city I find that term to be not
particularly helpful today
because what I see is globally what's
actually happening is that all cities
around the world are engaged in this
process of been we're going to talk a
little bit about building cities within
cities implanting like you see Stane
city or Machakos or elsewhere implanting
them within an existing urban fabric or
on the edges of existing urban fabrics
right so that places in Africa can find
can find out what the places are built
that are more connected to the world
economy more connected to New York to
London to Tokyo to Paris than they are
to what's ten you know ten miles outside
of outside of their borders and
increasingly increasingly the satellite
cities these news
these that are being constructed are
being constructed as enclaves completely
surrounded if you look at stain City for
example it's completely surrounded by a
wall and completely enclosed and it has
everything within those walls everything
within those walls that satisfy the kind
of criteria of work live and play that
people who live there don't really ever
have to leave there and in Johannesburg
in particular it's a it's a city that
has a very high crime rate and there's
equally high levels of fear of crime and
that justifies these kinds of projects
that enables real estate developers to
build them to encourage people to move
inside the gates and never leave a
friend of mine
Gavin chat can do right some cities in
India refers to this as bypass implant
urbanism and I think it's more the model
of what we're seeing in a world scale by
implant the implant part is building
enclaves for the rich and the super-rich
and those enclaves are no longer gated
communities just of residence but they
include commercial area shopping malls
and I'm going to show you Waterfall City
in a second which is building the
largest mall in Africa right next to one
of the biggest malls in Africa someone
is going to win and someone is going to
lose because there's not enough
consumers to buy all that stuff all the
Gucci stuff and so these new satellite
cities that are being constructed in
dozens of Africa African cities contain
within sites of work leisure
entertainment and residents they're not
like a gated community there are two or
three steps beyond a gated community and
I see this is the kind of future of
urbanism on a global scale we
less in the United States and less in
Europe but we see it in most most of the
rest of the world in this sense that
bite the bypass implant urbanism the
implant is implanting these zones of
wealth
Gavin shatkin my friend works on Manila
manila has a lot of us X US military
bases that are now being turned over to
real estate developers that are building
these enclaves for the wealthy Manila
has I don't know what 10 12 15 million
people and that's the implant the bypass
part is creating then corridors that
connect one rich place to another rich
place and the corridors take the form of
of dedicated roadways they take the form
of high-speed like in Johannesburg the
high-speed rail now a fast train 200
miles an hour fast train built by the
French that connects the rich areas of
Johannesburg and this is the pattern I
think that's that's taking place bypass
implant urbanism and in part what we saw
in somebody this little video that I
just showed you sort of reflects that
I'll be doing alright in time yeah we
have I would say 20 25 minutes in this
time for questions oh okay oh god my dog
just got to the preliminary parts but
that's all right for terms that I think
that really resonate that are really
helpful and aggregate urbanism seeing
cities as aggregated pieces rather than
we we have this kind of modernist
conception in our mind that cities
somehow have to be functionally
efficient they have to be connected to
have to be coherent I'm in an urban
planning program and my colleagues are
still wedded to this idea that somehow
what our job is is this is to pull the
urban fabric together I think that it
works in North America and and in Europe
but in other parts of the world it
doesn't work so we have to find a new
way of thinking about like what the role
of Reverend planning aggregate urbanism
modular urbanism fragmented city art
archipelago city the city of pieces we
have to find ways to think about then
this is it the the future of the way in
which cities are being built and the
extreme case of this are cities built
within cities built inside existing
cities so can let's show the Legos one
first that's the second one in a generic
yeah let me turn it for offer give you a
warm up in Legos the second or third
largest city in Africa a entirely new
project is being built a long debate of
the Gulf of Guinea called Eko Atlantic
land is being reclaimed from the
Atlantic Ocean an area the size of
Manhattan and you'll see from the video
what they're actually trying to do but
I'll jump ahead you know my conclusion
is what this is going to do is
incredibly fragment the existing city of
Lagos and in effect cement the exclusion
of the urban poor in order to serve the
interest of a privileged few the project
is being sponsored by the chigau reef
Amelie which are Nigerians of Lebanese
descent in alliance with the state
government and a lot of private
investment from elsewhere and you'll see
in the video a highly stylized image and
these images someone was just telling me
that they're actually I mean that my
facetious way of putting it is it's same
25 year old students that got degrees in
design that are sitting in an office in
Los Angeles and that are doing that
Machakos you can find a video in
Machakos they're doing the same videos
they all look alike they get a contract
to do it and they're just throwing this
stuff out as a way to sort of promote
these places as being up to date and so
forth so this is about two three minutes
because the economic capital of Nigeria
the most populated country in Africa
with its coastal location and the
fondant Natural Resources make us is
ideally positioned to take a leadership
role in the African economy and become a
major global force but the Gateway to
the continent needs a new headquarters
actual ending in the Aqsa rights in the
land reclaimed from the Atlantic Ocean
of Victoria Island in Lagos and
commenting its Africans brand new city
it will create prosperity and it will be
where business gets done southern Egypt
Nigeria limited the designers and city
fathers of Eko Atlantic are creating a
central boy bar in the first phase
business districts that will become
famous not only in Africa of the world
at large
the Bulevar will be about 2 kilometers
long and 60 metres wide similar in size
to the shops Elysees in Paris or 5th
Avenue in New York the whole business
district will be spread over some
700,000 square meters of development
opportunities a conceptual design for an
iconic power if they develop it stands a
northern end of the blue bar and will be
more than 50 stories high its
acquisition represents a high level of
investor confidence in our emergency
[Music]
this YW will feature an array of
additional towers finally to around an
average of 35 for
the center of violence inequality the
business district will also picture the
kilo condition of a luxury class
shopping mall for retail and commercial
use that takes business districts with
the impressive Boulevard running to it
as a centerpiece developers will not
only change the face of Legos it will
change the pace okay now of course you
can see that's a combination of various
elements on the one side there's highly
stylized images of these big tall
buildings and so forth that's actually
probably never going to happen anything
close to that and the other is this sort
of celebration of Lagos or Eko Atlantic
becoming the kind of financial hub for
Africa now a lot of other cities similar
projects I could show you a dozen maybe
two dozen very similar videos like this
all of which are promising very similar
outcomes but this is the kind of image
this is what's actually happening in
Africa some of these places are actually
existing Eko Atlantic is actually being
built the machacas one that I'd set
around it may never come to fruition
there's a picture in the machacas one of
a high-speed rail that would connect
Machakos to Nairobi never gonna happen
the cost is way too high and and it
would actually the building the
high-speed rail which is about as
expensive as building building Machakos
itself and urban planners and architects
that I talked to in Nairobi said well
why not do this in Nairobi why is anyone
want to come to Nairobi and then go 60
kilometers south it's just it's not
going to happen so
so these these places that that I mean
this one Eko Atlantic is gonna happen
it's not going to quite look like this
and notice in this in the stylized video
there's no poor people right there's no
people in formal traders on the street
which is what Lagos has those people
this place to look like this and to be
like this requires a draconian policing
force that is basically going to kick
the poor out and so my my view about
these things is rather than listen to
the celebratory rhetoric about what
great things are going to do for Africa
also look at the downside of it is what
things are going to do in order to make
them happen which is to build in effect
that kind of a kind of police state for
for these for these locations yeah
thanks for interrupting that's good no
no it's fine I want you to yeah yeah
they're not going to live there they're
going to live somewhere else and like
the stain the stain city one that I
passed around this Dow stain guy it is a
piece of work as a person I won't go
into all the details of them I mean what
someone a friend of mine who actually
worked with him said that he's in his
eighties he's got cancer it's basically
the first thing he built was this
gigantic the biggest house in Africa for
himself and for his family they have six
floors of parking base for the 300 cars
that the family owns right and he shows
up in his bathrobe with someone walking
behind him with gin and tonics it's just
the Megillah men make megalomania kind
of project but it embeds within it
certain features that resonate within
the kind of rest of the world let me
just finish the thought that resonate
with the rest of the world is like 50
percent of the space there is going to
be green space I've been there it's
going to be green
face walking past bike paths and so
forth so it brings in all these kind of
new urbanist elements but with a
completely encapsulated sight
yeah it's not but how does something
like that I was looking at that how does
that fly in a country with the history
that South Africa has I mean I was there
in 98 and to see this now it's so
disappointing yeah how does it fly there
are one or two nice black people in
there yeah security says oh my god what
any good yes on pennilyn cities and it
might have been about this but what I
recall was the security system involved
like retinal scans when you
after that barrier we'll get anywhere in
here yeah I'll talk about the next one
I'll talk about do that more yes
absolutely the solution you're showing
this because in Atlanta which is my
opinion make to the rhythmic choices to
build two new stadiums one our school
system for Terry and and one of the
state the baseball stadium is really
about a mile and a half from where I
live and the area that they're trying to
reject refine the entire air to to bring
it out but there's low-income housing
and all those people will be forced out
outlets man it's similar it reminds me
very much of a very gentrification which
is taking place in very many cities I
mean you mentioned Detroit I would
imagine that whole center of town
project they've been doing is probably
selling people yeah yeah it's another
event to Detroit but it's just very
fascinating that it's it's almost like
they're mirroring a lot of what we did
with our cities when we reject Rifai the
nice the poor areas
yeah yeah
Detroit is a special case in a lot of
ways I mean my view about the tour I'm
very dystopian about it this Detroit is
being reborn it's being reborn by Dan
Gilbert who owns the Cleveland Cavaliers
and made the contract with LeBron James
and a company called Quicken Loans and
they're rebuilding the center of Detroit
but there also happens to be about 700
or 800 thousand people in Detroit mostly
African Americans who have been
abandoned by the city and are being
abandoned by Dan Gilbert and so it's a
new Detroit and it's a Detroit not being
reborn it's been a tutorial in my view
it's it's excluding the the current
residents to even further deprivation on
the margins despite the rhetoric Garth
well I was just gonna say I studied one
of these developments as well exam vo it
was the but Chinese company and when I
asked the developer who is very proud of
all of the security apparatus and all of
the the green development both the
greenery and the sort of eco-friendly
architecture and I asked you know who is
going to be doing the security service
and who would be maintaining of
the lawns and treaties and she said that
they would you know they would have
contracts for that and I asked where
those people would live and there was no
provision for that whatsoever and so
what happens in have seen this in enough
of other African countries no I'm still
any marks on but those people have no
provision in the new landscape but so
they create their own and so in each of
these places what happens is another new
city happens to which is an informal
salad yeah yeah absolutely yeah I guess
I have our tumblr got scared kind of a
reaction to this and that
two things one never build in these huge
places right in this climate of climate
change you know and I worry about that
but then I also have this dystopian sort
of if there's a populist uprising I'm
wondering this kind of environment I
find is terrifying and I'm not coming to
Africa you know but I'm also thinking
about a lumen Boston the whole Back Bay
was all filled in and the city was
doubled in size and I think the city is
still trying to figure out how to
maintain that long term and this is at a
much larger scale
I'm just thinking two three four hundred
years out how are they going to be able
to maintain that sort of fighting nature
there's no thought to that whatsoever
already there's the the building that's
the group that called it the great wall
of Legos mimicking the Great Wall of
China where they're putting their
building putting in you know reclaiming
the land it's already caused erosion and
both you know on both sides in other
countries along along the coast let me
show you this last one because I see I'm
running out of time and this is the
place I've actually this is the place
called waterfall city I've I've worked
I've done research on this place for
over five years it's actually a place I
know I know the best this is between
Johannesburg and Pretoria right next to
stain City
and this is a real place it does exist
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for time he can just come you can find
that on you I were running out of time
but I did want to talk about this
because it picks up at very two very
different themes one of which that you
mentioned Waterfall city is divided into
14 separate precincts as you can tell
it's a huge place
it's bigger obviously bigger than down
the existing downtown Johannesburg
they're building a mall which is going
to be they say you're going to be the
biggest mall in Africa and this
emphasizes primarily the corporate part
of it there's a number of different
residential components of that that
ranked that from really high scale
what's called the equestrian estates
which are big plots where everyone has a
horse and access to stables and stuff
like that
2/3 retirement villages the first
private medical school in in South
Africa and then a a private medical
school private hospital and in health
clinics because they're catering to the
business of taking care of old people
and and then entertainment you know the
the security system is incredible I
don't want to go into great detail but
to get into any one of the precincts
it's both fingerprint identification
system license plate identification
within 7 seconds they can tell whether
the car is legitimate or not what it's
been stolen or not stolen and and I scan
because it put your finger over like
this you have your picture taken they
have a picture identification and then
there's retinal scans as well so the
security is incredible
now what are the peculiar features about
this place that are a bit shocking and
unusual it's owned by a single family
the family of Ismail Mia a devout Muslim
family that originally came to South
Africa in the 1860s to work in sugar in
the sugar plantations in the town
came from the Indian subcontinent the
Ismail me a family then became
shopkeepers made a lot of money and
bought this land which was then in
middle of nowhere between Johannesburg
and Pretoria and they put a mosque on
the land and used and used their income
in order to fund projects for
particularly orphan Muslim children all
over the world they were convinced by a
group of real-estate the younger people
in the family in their 40s two men in
the family one a lawyer and one a
businessman we're convinced by
real-estate developers look you have to
do something with this land it's the
most it's the price of the premier
property in the metropolitan region
developers then on two sides came
together and formed a company called
waterfall investment company the other
peculiar feature about this place it's a
completely private city right in
accordance with the quran and muslim law
what i was told in the interviews was
they cannot because it was religious
land they could not sell it so the land
is not sold the land is rented so any
one of these investment these big
corporates that are there don't own the
land they own their building but they
don't own the land where it sits and so
this creates a in perpetuity a financial
stream to the mia family which then uses
the money to invest in their global
projects around help for you know
disadvantaged muslims all over the world
they are a very modest family I've seen
where the family lives and their
facilities are very modest there are
about 25 to 30 businesses in this
waterfall city every single one of them
is privately owned so access to water
access to electricity and
and the most up-to-date
telecommunication systems probably in
Africa they're directly connected to the
that cable that comes across the ocean
and it lands and near Mombasa I think
for high-speed you know for the the kind
of digital high-speed Internet services
and so forth they're not dependent upon
the municipality or even a Johannesburg
government for anything they buy water
in bulk they buy electricity in bulk
divide it up into pieces and then sell
it with a private company to residents
there are no police stations there is no
public presence in this place whatsoever
all the policing is done by a private
company called
under contract on seven arrows which is
one of the most brutal companies in in
Johannesburg and eventually they're
going to create their own company and
then everything else is divided up into
pieces the first private Medical School
in South Africa a private hospital which
is unusual in South Africa so it's a
completely privately owned profit driven
enterprise it's not a city it's a
profit-making machine and it's fancy a
few other distinctive features and
relationship to the South African
Constitution which is one of the most
progressive constitutions in the world
and a South African Parliament which has
maybe the second or third largest number
of women representatives in Parliament
by law because this is private property
and the property cannot be purchased but
can only be acquired through long-term
lease so homeowners if you want to buy
in the Equestria in the States you can
get that for on a 99 year lease which is
automatically renewed every year so at
the end of the year it's again another
99 year lease the commercial commercial
property is on a 49 year lease but again
renewed automatically Atteberry
becomes one of the construction
companies has also done a trick here
which is they they've done the same
thing that waterfall investment company
did which is they then own most of the
buildings which they then rent to the
corporates they will build them to
specification so it's a kind of rent
making you know rent seeking operation
it's really unusual but I think it's a
kind of prototype for what's going to
take off in the rest of Africa as we see
new cities being built they're going to
be increasingly built as private
profit-making machines where the public
presence doesn't exist
right there's no public police the rules
and regulations are established by
waterfall investment company I saw the
book which they refer to as the Bible in
in it's kind of a spoof against the
Quran which is what the Mia family
consulted about how to deal with this
property the book then gives them all
their rules and regulations they have
complete control over what people build
and so forth I went around with one of
the leading developers he stopped in
front of a house in the questioning
States he took out his tape measure and
he said that wall that they built it's
two inches too high he wrote it down
we're calling our lawyers and they're
going to take that fence down colors
styles shapes the whole environment is
constructed according of
to a single rulebook with respect to the
Constitution there are no Christian
churches in waterfall city there's a
mosque there are no Christian churches
which is a surprise there is no liquor
by the drink there are no nightclubs
there are no liquor stores you can buy
alcohol in a supermarket if that's not
the only thing being sold you can buy
pork but it's not it can't be the
dominant meat meat being sold so there's
kind of a imposition of certain rules
and regulations that come from another
place that get imposed upon this layered
upon this place so I see it in a way as
an extreme version of what may be the
future of city building and Africa and I
could sort of out of time on this so but
this is what I would you know what I
would suggest that we that we think
about